[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
desperate for sports the tournament to
play for heroes and had a little fun
doing it I would love to put Mickelson
in the slot let him meet Ray Lewis this
is the trophy for the match I don't know
actually tell you if you know what this
looks like he's from a woman chili yeah
I would have loved to have had this
tournament in a place where they don't
like Tom very much Indianapolis Denver
Boston competing I'll let you know
channeling all my negative energy right
now to make you miss this putt they're
going to hit some really bad ones and
look like that the amateur golfers that
they are the match champions for charity
the return to competition because we've
got to play off
[Music]
I'm just worried about that pumpkin
crowd noise in there you know if he
starts making putts like they used to
I would love nothing more than to give
him a memory of me beating him on his
home court
maybe I need he live down there to kind
of help me out there will be no excuses
he doesn't know like woods okay he just
hates to lose obviously no room for
second place
we know woman he has zero match belts
zero father that actually thought I was
gonna have a partner but then Peyton's
dad called and switched the team welcome
everybody inside the brl welcome
everybody to Capital One's the match
beat PR and welcome everybody to live
sports we did it we did it this is not
3:00 a.m. baseball this is not a draft
this is for the greatest athletes of our
generation going head to head for our
entertainment who are the best golfers
of all time tiger and Phil they don't
like each other they didn't back then
they don't today Tom Brady Peyton
Manning - the greatest quarterbacks of
our lives bitter rivals forever they
battle it out and this is beat Br I'm
gonna promise you three things as you
watch right here in the BRF number one
star studded line from Super Bowl MVPs
to NBA Hall of Famers number two cold
hard cash you are on your couch and you
can win $1,000 yes that is happening a
little bit later and number three
possibly the biggest hoodie giveaway in
B our history and that all happens today
there's only one person that could get
in our way and that is the really big
brain behind B are betting they always
incomparable Kelly Stewart Kelly you're
ready to crush some dreams today Adam
I'm always ready to crush those hopes
and dreams I love that it is gonna be a
medalist golf club down there in hope
sound Florida it's supposed to be wet
and wild so we'll keep you updated as we
get information as well but here is how
beat BR is going to work the viewers you
guys in me we are on a squad the
opponent that we're going up against
Kelly Stewart don't worry I got your
back we are building a cart of eight
prop bets
Kelly is building a cart of eight prop
bets
whoever wins more wins and if we win I'm
giving out these hoodies I went into the
VR vault I got them all ready to go
hundreds of hoodies will be given away
and as Kelly sits there and thinks oh I
have the better card
not so fast Kelly all week long you guys
the viewers have been picking our first
seven prop bets on our social media
channels B are betting on IG and Twitter
you guys use the draftkings odds you
killed it
we will reveal those throughout the show
but our last bet bet number 8 hashtag
team tiger or hash tag team Phil that's
what I got that's what I need you guys
to do in the comment section right now
so who do you think is gonna win who you
got get in the comment section right now
hashtag team tiger or hash tag team Phil
and if we end up choosing the site you
picked you are eligible to win so get in
the comment section right now Kelly
you've been up on the odds all week all
day where is the smart money going right
now
you know that's difficult where's the
smart money going I don't know if it's
necessary smart money but it's a lot of
money coming in on Team Phil late we
just saw $17,000 bet come across from
our buddies over at droppings they told
us that there is heavy money coming in
on Team Phil now team Tiger was as high
as - 215 middle of the week guess what
that team Phil Oakey said he hates to
lose obviously entice enough people to
plunk down some heavy cash look I also
know that we got Dana White who put 15
grand on Tom Brady and Phil Mickelson
Kelly last time you bet on Tiger Woods
let's recap the first match to set out
what we're going to see today you bet on
Tiger how did that pan out for you out
there at shadow Creek in Las Vegas I
actually felt great going into it I laid
a shorter number with Tiger than most
people and Tiger was coming in clutch
for me and then it all
went away yeah this was on 16 the punch
from the rough able to get it to go the
beautiful birdie right there and people
were going here is the surge here's what
we needed and then it got really dark
the celebrities crowded around Ben
Stiller the pressure yeah I just had Ben
Stiller Tiger Woods
unable to get this winning putt to fall
and then a little bit later as the dust
began to really settle Phil Mickelson
pushed in the putt and took home the
nine million dollars winning this one
all the bragging rights and all those
bags of cash really really special to be
there and be a part of it even more
special that this time it is going to
involve Tom Brady and Peyton Manning so
one more time just another quick recap
we're building our card of eight bets
Kelly has her card of eight bets seven
of the bets were on our social channels
earlier this week but our eighth and
most important bet who you got we need
you to fill out in the comments section
right now either hashtag team tiger or
hash tag team Phil so that's that bottom
eight one right there the rest we will
reveal over the next hour we have
thousands of dollars to give away so
stay tuned it will be amazing
in the meantime everyone's weighing in
who you got last at let's ask pro ball
quarterback Matt Ryan who he's siding
with
[Music]
hey what's up this is Matt Ryan I'm
really excited to watch the match this
week between Tiger and Peyton and Phil
and Tom I obviously think it's gonna be
a close one but I have some some inside
info I got to play golf
yesterday with Phil Mickelson he was
dropping bombs off the tee his calves
looked like they were a great shape so
I'm gonna go with Phil and Tom I think
they've got the slight edge all right so
we heard right there Kelly that Phil
Mickelson is hitting bombs and the
calves are looking like perfection Kelly
does that impact your betting at all you
know it doesn't appreciate Matt Ryan's
insight but it doesn't really get it's
not gonna sway me one way or another
listen he's a he's a great quarterback
but I'm not sure how often he gets out
to the links agreed now we do know one
person loves to get on the links and
that is Charles Barkley
we just don't know if he's any good only
kidding Uncle Chuck I love you but we
did ask Charles one question on the
front nine when it is gonna be that
better ball scoring who gets more Park
who gets more pars or better on that
front nine Tom or Peyton let's see which
one he picked I will probably say Payton
is gonna make less bogeys because he's
probably been prepared more you know tom
has been breaking into people houses and
hey that's what you know you to go when
you can just walk and talk about a house
and they don't shoot your ass that's
when you know you're to go
I think that's exactly what Kelly Chuck
never disappoints ever Kelly he's great
listen you can't deny it all he said was
absolute facts right there all right so
he's going with Payton who was - 125 Tom
plus 105 now Berkeley he told me earlier
this week he can't wait to have an open
mic the entire time to trash-talk these
guys for hours but there is one time
that he has to get on the course and
show his golfing skill 18th hole he's
got to play and he's got to try and get
a bogey or better before the squad and
Kelly weighs in we asked the for golfers
if they think Chuck and get it done here
are their answers Berkeley is gonna play
the 18th hole to try to make a bogey or
better for $200,000 on the line for
charity what is your prediction you know
I worry about his grip on the club
that's I'm not a sweat that's gonna be
taking place with the humidity and
Charles's fitness I think he could make
a bogey he's got to get off the tee
Charles is a competitor he's one of the
toughest most clutch athletes that's
ever lived
I think he's scrappy enough to make it
happen he's going to find a way with
that horrific golf swing to make a bogey
or better I would say the charity and
he's look for some work another place to
get the money cuz it's just not gonna
happen
I don't care what TZ plays for it's not
gonna happen I have no doubt that this
will be one of the most entertaining
parts of the day unfortunately for our
first squad bet you the viewers and me
unfortunately for Chuck we are going
with no he will not get a bogey or
better and we are taking that at minus
240 so we're not going with the value we
are going with common sense Kelly our
competitor do you agree with us should
we have taken no there I have to agree
with you and the only thing that sucks
about this one is we have to wait till
the 18th pull the seat chuck score a 7
or worse there is no way this man
Charles I love you you're a hilarious
man but there is no way he's getting a
bogey or better on this 18th hole it is
narrow it is long and look at that golf
swing yeah but what about all those
Phoenix Coyotes he's playing with that
say he's gotten better Kelly I mean I
hope he's gotten better now that he's
got some more free time to play golf but
better than that Adam I still a bogey
professional golfers have double bogeyed
this hole with ease I hope he cups it
2nd squad
no he cups it but for betting purposes
he doesn't will Tom or Peyton hit a shot
out of bounds that is the second squad
bet and you guys have weighed in on the
B are betting Channel and you guys have
gone with yes you have chosen that
Payton or Tom will hit a ball out of
bounds during capital ones the matched
champions for charity coming up later
today on TNT they're saying out of
bounds Kelly was that a good decision by
the squad I do not like that I'm chewing
Oh with the squad so far this is not
good for me yes I do agree with the
squad here while both guys are good
golfers we know that Peyton's a six
handicap and that Tom's an 8 handicap
I'm gonna read between the lines here
and if you listened to their interviews
on TNT with Ernie Johnson they both kind
of admitted this course has gotten the
best of them
Tom's shot over a hundred the last time
out
Payton lost his entire sleeve of balls
you know what that means that means he
went out of bounds just a few times
especially with all the rain we're
expecting it should be very interesting
but listen this is beat Br this is the
game show around the biggest sporting
events that are happening and we don't
just want to enjoy the events we want to
give you guys cash and hoodies so again
get in the comments section either hash
tag team Phil or team Tiger to help us
with our eighth bet and I'm ready to
give away a thousand dollars and it all
comes down to this Kelly we're putting
on the spot a little quarantine
challenge you have to hit a putt and so
I need people in the comment section
right now comment either yes or no
whether or not you think Kelly is gonna
make the putt Kelly how are you feeling
a lot of pressure
lots of pressure Adam for those of you
that don't know I have spent some time
on a golf course but I would say this is
probably a 50/50 proposition I've been
practicing a lot I'm a little nervous
right now I would be lying if I always
said I wasn't I think it's important
with golf to see how people do under
pressure better yet let's see how they
do under crazy circumstances I found
this footage of you Kelly at the driving
range with Ojo Cinco and the bee are
betting guys hey guys let's see how
Kelly does when the cameras are on sorry
mom and dad
longest ride there we go focus focus
Kelly if you talk in my [ __ ]
back swings I'm going to beat your this
is a game of patience not meaning I'm
gonna freak out I'm sorry okay you know
it's like a golf course you got to be
stuck yeah you do got to be okay thank
you for the advice come over it cuz it
you can't do that like either gonna play
we're gonna do it right where we warmed
up and everything under the begin I'm
not doing this we're gonna do it a
spread our I'm gonna throw a pitching
wedge and Greg's backswing like you want
to do for our we can do it we're gonna
play a game we can play a game I still
have a hundred on Kelly
[Music]
what I do laundry on Kelly no I'm not
doing this
see that's the benefit of being in
quarantine no one to speak in Kelly's
backswing I have the BR app open right
here to see which two people I'm gonna
make eligible to win $1,000 you're on
your couch you better be in the comment
section k Balt ba ult has voted Kelly
will make the putt
you are the person voting yes I'm going
to choose all earn nothing betting know
that Kelly will miss the putt so if
Kelly makes it k Balt
you and a thousand dollars if she misses
it all or nothing you win a thousand
dollars here it is Kelly good luck
alright Adam it's time to redeem myself
as well as one in one of our squad
members thousand bucks
get in the hole let's go baby
and just like that Kelly has won $1,000
Kay bolts congratulations guys if you
are not in the comment section
participating right now you may have
just missed out on $1,000 kay ball
didn't congratulations Kelly I'm not
gonna lie you were a little bit closer
than I thought you were gonna be but you
still put it in the cup congratulations
proud of you very much proud of you
all right so coming up the 6 the 6-foot
putt was what we had agreed on when I
when I first saw the mat name is 9 feet
I go come on guys you got to give me a
little bit of benefited out of here
let's let's make it more of a 50/50
proposition 9 foot that have been kind
of hard alright so k ball wins $1,000
here is the next opportunity to win
$1,000 in our bet on anything challenge
we have a Bentley full of golf balls
this is an optical illusion I still
can't figure it out you guys need to
guess whether it's over or under the
line that Kelly is gonna set for golf
balls in that Bentley there's a
regulation-size golf balls Kelly what
are you setting the line at for how many
golf balls are in that Bentley and we're
gonna set the line at 655 golf ball I
know it sounds a little high and at
first I said you know I was looking at
it I was talking to the producers
because I don't know how many balls are
actually in there but when I set the
line much lower they said hey Ivy you
got to pump that number up there that
mini Bentley isn't as small as it looks
okay so get in the comments section
right now either over or under we're
gonna get back to that in a little bit
and that way we'll figure out who's up
for the $1,000 we'll check back in but
we need to keep building out our card
and who better to help us with these
props than one of the greatest safeties
of all time and Reed
[Music]
whose went in the match between Phil
Mickelson Tom Brady Tiger Woods and
Peyton Manning man now that is a good
match I can't pick Peyton a Brady
because they're both my guys both the
legends I played against a boat and I
always say 180 one beat you know
greatest quarterbacks you know that I
face I can't pick Peyton over Brady
because Brady blessed my son on his
birthday you know and I can't pick Brady
over Peyton because Peyton took me to
Augusta you know so I just want to see a
good match between those guys man and
may the best man win
I love Edie Reed's hair right now the
hair and the beard phenomenal I hate the
fact that he decided not to pick anybody
Kelly that's ridiculous
come on this is B PR this is B PR I
wanted something definitive from Edie
but he's just one of those nice guys you
know you've got to be able to pick a
side here and that's what I'm here for
be definitive win some cash yes so maybe
instead of someone that played against
them will choose someone that has played
with both of them Wes Welker wide
receiver for the Patriots and the
Broncos we asked him who will head a
longer drive on a hole one let's see
which way Welker went
which player wat the longest drive on
the first team yeah I'm gonna say Payton
does he's always been a guy gets off to
good starts in games and he's always
done well you know especially early on
in the games and getting that lead and
on how to play with the lead
so wes welker they're going with the
favorite Peyton Manning at minus 137 tom
was even in terms of which one would
drive the furthest on a hole one all
I've been hearing Kelly is that Brady's
got about thirty more yards than the
driver so this is a bit surprising to me
I have also heard that Adam but from
what I've been told is that Peyton
actually hired a golf coach and has been
working on his driver here and I think
that's why we've seen him be better that
seems to be kind of common knowledge 137
is a little steep but I will agree with
Wes here I think Peyton's the right side
alright squad let's go were beaten up
Kelly Stewart squad bet number three
they chose for us we'll Tom Brady hit
the fairway on that hole one this was
the odds yes plus 100
no minus 130 for these are the odds that
we got it at and guess what squad we are
going with yes Tom Brady will hit the
ball on the fairway feeling pretty good
about it Kelly
should we feel good I know it's narrow
it is narrow hole number one is narrow
there are several narrow holes at
medalist and don't forget we do have
some wind and some weather blowing
through there so that could come into
play as well the good news for tom is he
gets a tee off from the blue tees
instead of the tiger tips which are the
Proteas there at medalist I do think
that's gonna give him somewhat of an
advantage but I'm gonna lay it again no
- 130 ish I don't think that he's gonna
make it in the fairway here again
everybody it's gonna be at medallist
Golf Club and the front nine is gonna be
best balls like a Ryder Cup scoring the
back nine will be that alternate shot
fourth bet free the squad you guys and
me take it on Kelly will Grunk
named Grunk be said by any player so not
Berkeley or Trevor Immelman or my man ba
on the call will Grunk be said by any
player yes plus 100 no minus 120
guess what it is yes the squad is going
with yes so we had another yes on that
squad bet it's now plus 100 we got it it
even so not a ton of value Kelly but
what do you think you think Gronk gets
mentioned oh man I hate how much that
I'm agreeing with a squad here I do
think Gronk gets mentioned in some sort
of fun casual way maybe we hear it from
Phil dang Adam I really want to be going
head-to-head with you guys on some of
these would make me feel better but I
guess I'll just have to go ain't no on
my card I know we're betting a ton on
these four guys so I really need to
figure out who wants it more the good
news is you interviewed these guys
earlier on in the week so I think you
have some intel on who really wants this
Wow
I just got off with Tom Brady Phil
Mickelson Tiger Woods and Peyton Manning
and their media train smiles and
friendly words may make this seem
innocent but this is a golf match
between four of the most competitive men
to ever walk planet Earth
I want these guys to destroy each other
soul so I'm gonna help them express
themselves with the trash talk
translator first up let's see what
peyton has to say about Tom he's won six
Super Bowls he's earned every one of
them Hank if it wasn't for my mother
Olivia man to eat had 11 of them but
what he meant was my seven-year-old
mother could outdrive you Tom she halved
your Super Bowls
Olivia Manning Fano snapped your ass
your response Tom I'm in a locked room
full of 22 years all the time now I got
the all these older guys I'm the young
guy finally I think that brings back a
little bit of this youthful spirit that
I've had translation I'm a young 40 to
old man I know how to change zoom
backgrounds while you're busy setting
your life
to remind you which guy in the
commercials you are let's see what Phil
has to say about Tiger if I can go to
his home course and win there and I've
got the partner to do it with break that
would be a pretty cool memory that I
will I will relive that more and more to
in the future lock your doors Tiger
Woods I'm going to embarrass you in your
own home and then tattoo the memory onto
my left hand so I think about it every
time that I put your rebuttal Tiger
biggest thing that I've learned from
Phil is that he's always gonna try
something what could that mean phil is a
trickster god
and most people tom anything to say
about Tiger Tiger kinda has a lot of
football injuries I'm not quite sure how
that happened over time where's your
offensive line Tiger huh tag what do you
have to say to Phil about your many more
championship do you really need another
championship you got six
winning Super Bowls is selfish Tom give
me the good what's the meanest thing
that you have to say to people so you've
actually a very good golfer he's a
terrible golfer Phil let's go for Tigers
just mental that's competitive there
probably ever is in any sport you hear
that Tiger Bill didn't compliment your
tactical game
[Music]
medallist isn't even that art lefty keep
up Matt has been the trash talk trans
[Music]
all right well let's go calms down let's
figure out who's gonna win the cash on
this one now I set the line on the
number of golf balls in the mini bitly
at 655 it looks like we have Gasca one
has the over and Mady underscore P 3d
has the under
[Music]
hey 716 golf balls in that badly I still
don't understand
but that means Gasca won congratulations
$1,000 you're on your couch and now
$1,000 are coming to you Kelly hack of a
line I don't know how you did that that
was impressive I get a lot of help from
my friends Adam good huh so we put you
on the spot earlier with the putt and of
course they're dialing it up for me for
the chip so let me show you guys really
quick this will be your next opportunity
to win $1,000 okay you see that little
target over there I've been practicing
all the one that was like 4 times in all
week but that's what I get today I have
to come over here and I'm gonna drill it
if you think I'm gonna make it I need
you to put yes in the comment section
below if you think that I'm gonna miss
it I need you to put know in the comment
section below and if you're on the team
that's right you will win $1,000 if we
choose you if you don't enter it right
now you're possibly missing out on
$1,000 get in there you know who's not
gonna miss out on an opportunity to make
money Kirk Cousins
yeah fat stacks let's see who he likes
in Capital One's the match well I'm
looking forward to the match just like
everybody else my prediction is that
Payton and Tiger get the win over Tom
and Phil and here are my reasons one
it's Tiger Woods enough said to Peyton
Manning's been retired for like four
years now he's had a lot of time to work
on his golf swing Tom's been out in
parks still throwing and working out
trying to get ready for the football
season so that makes it hard to get your
golf game dialed in so for those reasons
I'm going with Tiger and Peyton but
it'll be fun to watch
whoever wins
so hopefully those guys have a blast and
can raise some great money to help a lot
of people during a difficult time
all right so Kirk Cousins is great and
I'm super happy that he went that way
but it's time for us to get some real
juice I'm going on my phone I'm going on
my phone book I'm going to the Super
Bowl MVP
we're FaceTime and Pat mahomes I need
him to make a prop bet see Pat mahomes
let's see if he picks out he better pick
out I hope he doesn't pick up listen I'm
gonna have you look at the camera cuz
you're big time all right your Super
Bowl MVP first of all what do you think
of this match which way you lean in and
and and how do you feel about an event
like this don't pick yet don't pick yet
don't think yet okay so here we have a
profit that I need your help with Cole
number five it is the Capital One Club
challenge where all four golfers are
gonna have to use just one club to get
through who would you go with to win
that whole Brady and fill or Manning and
tiger and why is really good with and
that he actually won a tournament so I
gotta go with Manning and tiger on that
one Wow they're the favorite right now
so that's pretty good okay now overall
you were saying it earlier who are you
picking the with it who you got team
tiger or team Phil okay so I have to hit
a chip in like two minutes to possibly
win someone $1,000 one do you think I'm
gonna make it and two
would your advice be about 810 feet and
the targets like this big that's what
I'm doing I'm punching you're the man's
hat I'll see you later penny all right
man see ya dude okay so he is going on
the Capital One Club challenge with
Payton some incredible inside
information but he is going with team
Tiger to win it all
what do you think of that inside info
there Kelly hey listen Adam you know
anytime I get it I take it I love that
inside info and this was one of the
tougher ones for me to try to look at
and actually figure out who was gonna do
better with one club like you said which
club are they gonna use I mean if it's
me I just use a driver all the way
through but that's beside the point
also I have been against Patrick mahomes
enough I'm not betting against him again
so I was riding with patty mahomes and
his advice here all right so our thanks
to Patrick mahomes that was really
really cool now let's get back to our
squad bets
squad bet number five in our card to
beat Br knock off Kelly Stewart when
hundreds of hoodies which team will go
one up first which team is going to take
the lead first today team Phil was plus
110 team Tiger was minus 150 and what do
you know the squad bet here going with
team Phil and team Tom Brady and it is
going to be plus 110 Kelly do you agree
on that one Wow I'm actually shocked to
see that usually we don't see these guys
take the underdog here but I have to
disagree hi I hate to break it to you
guys there's a reason why team tiger is
the heavier favorite at minus 150 here
and that is because they're gonna be the
first ones to go 1up now is there a ton
of value there at 150 no so I know why
they're taking the +1 Ted but that's
gonna be a nice winner for me
okay now squad bet number six this one
if it happens it'll be a magical moment
that'll be on Br
and the IG all the time will anyone hole
out from off green so this is a lot like
what we saw in the match one where Tiger
kind of punched it in from 16 will we
get any special shot for a really nice
birdie or nice eagle and the squad is
going with very intelligently know
granted it's at minus 345 so there's not
a lot of value I don't care about value
I'm just trying to beat Br
no Kelly do you agree or do you think
somebody would hit one of those magical
shots tonight you know some of these
profits are rather chalky and they are
for that very reason
Adam when's the last time you hold out
for off the green back in nineteen it
never happened I've never hold out Kelly
is that your point it's kind of my point
because neither have I it's not an easy
thing to do and actually we talked about
perceived value and at three to one
while that is pricey it is a very tough
shot especially going giving that this
is a charity golf tournament as opposed
to 9 million dollars on the line it's
gonna be a lot more casual I think the
squad is right here with no I have
talked to 7 different athletes over the
last few days about who do they think is
gonna win three of them pick team Tiger
three of them pick team Phil one of them
didn't respond and I think there's one
person that understands that a lot and
that's our own cabbie Richards he asked
some of his famous friends who you got
and here are their responses we don't
each other for a long time
and you know that I struggle with a lot
of things I struggle with snacking amen
you know even kidding I struggle with
personal space
I struggle with them betting and and
golf and you become an avid golfer and a
fan of golf so this is where I need your
help my G
okay we're thinking about you the match
twos coming up his team Tiger vs. team
Phil I don't know where to put my
bangles like I'm hitting you up for this
how much you spend that's like tiger and
pay is gonna be super serious because
like they're gonna strategize and pee
and always gonna audible and I think
tiger and Phil might find themselves in
some places they've never found
themselves before the things you learn
from the back gyroscope focus on himself
and understanding that who he is that no
doubts I get to him he consistently just
worries about what he's doing in the
course so I was like very publicly team
Phil so you know I would even it out and
the two tigers I got film TV me
personally I've literally seen tiger
[Music]
that settles it team tiger I want to go
big though I wanna like hey I borrow
some money to make a wager shot you have
mo I mean what do I get in return
unlimited high-fives and hugs when we
return to no yeah hey do you want to
play zoom trivia we have a zoom happy
hour want to make a tip talk together I
love my best friends
[Music]
oh that reminds me cabbie solos me a
little bit of money from our Jalen Hertz
but Adam left oh are you ready to win or
lose people some money man I hope so but
I'm gonna be honest this target is
really tiny and it's a little bit
crossed up I need to know who bet that I
would hit it and who bet that I wouldn't
so that I can get motivated Kelly so
Eric I'm sorry ecoan nine said yes
Richie Rich 99 said no Wow Richie Rich
real punk that's the kind of parenting
you're getting with those wealthy kids
okay I much like Payton on the capital
100 challenge I am using a six I am
gonna smash it through the target I just
missed four in a row
this is for all I hate us out there
thank you
Richie Rich you little turd okay drum
roll please silence man it felt so not
good at all
ah you know what you know who would have
made that shot sue bird would have made
that shot let's listen to her and stop
embarrassing me man what's up everybody
sue bird here I've got Tiger and Peyton
you know I feel like tiger and Phil
could go either way but Tigers got that
added a sense if he lost in the match
last year and then Peyton
I mean he's retired so I'll respect to
Tom who's still still playing I totally
respect that but Peyton's in that
retired life and you know what that
means probably a little hot ago
alright I'm not just saying this because
I'm trying to redeem myself but I
literally just hit it on the next shot
so I'm really sorry two eco and nine
richy-rich
enjoy your $1,000 that's what you get
here oh don't buzzer me by the way I
need you guys to hear this I'm getting
news right now in my little IFB that the
rain that's down there and hope sound is
looking like a band that may pass which
means we're gonna get live sports today
we're gonna get live sports today very
excited almost as excited to fill out
our betting card Kelly Stewart because
the last $1,000 that we're giving away
is all about that eighth bet get in the
comment section right now let us know
who you got either hashtag team tiger or
hash tag team Phil if we end up choosing
that name we are gonna pick one of you
guys on the right side to possibly win
$1,000 so that's the big thing get in
the comment section right now hashtag
team Tiger hashtag team Phil in the mean
time you saw cabbie was speaking with
Michelle Wie Michelle was asked will a
playoff be needed will this go to extras
let's see what she says I don't know I
think this year with alternate-shot
being the second half of the match I
don't think there will be a playoff I
think there's gonna be a momentum shift
and you know with alternate shot if you
go either one way or another and if you
don't find your rhythm nine holes is
really not a long time to find your
rhythm back controls in a shot if you
lost it so I think it can be pretty
deciding the last two bubbles
arie Michelle we saying no it is gonna
be very interesting what she's saying it
started off at no minus a thousand it's
down a minus five ninety Kelly do you
think we're playing into the night or
does this end at eighteen I don't think
we're playing into the night but that
line move should tell you something a
lot of people started betting on yes I
don't think it's going to I think
Michelle's right there is gonna be a
momentum shift on the back nine who
pulls ahead we're gonna find out but I
don't think so this is not as cutthroat
as last time it's not gonna be dark this
one's gonna be over by four p.m. on the
west coast let us get to the seventh
squad bet as we go to beat PR and unlock
hundreds of hoodies when tiger is ballin
you see a lot of this Hey the club twirl
and they have set the line at two and a
half Club twirls it's minus 110 for yes
minus 110 for no and what do you know
our squad is believing that Tigers gonna
have a heck of a day they are going with
yes at minus 110 Kelly do you think
Tigers gonna be spinning they spit in
what do you think you know we just
mentioned this is gonna be a casual golf
game compared to last time I think Tiger
is gonna be happy he's gonna be at ease
I think we see that Club spit in
chocolate so the bookmakers turn 1/2 is
a great number but if this was gonna
come down to the wire he pulls one out
on 17 or 18 we're gonna get that third
Club twirl I hate to say it but man the
squad and I are agreeing a lot today
that's amazing and it's gonna come down
again as the capital ones the match is
going on on TNT make sure you're
following along on all the B are betting
channels IG Twitter will be updating in
the BR app as well updating our card
verses Kelly's card so you guys know if
we're on our way to a mountain of
hoodies now we are going to reveal
Kelly's card she's been talking about it
we need to see what we're up against
okay Kelly are you ready to reveal some
of those monster picks you've made
I sure have Adam it's been a fun week
trying to lock down just seven of these
but I think we got it taken care of okay
the first bet on your
card which team wins the first hole
there was some juice there on both teams
but you went with a tie what's the
reason you went there you know we talked
about this hole number one is super
narrow from the tips we mentioned that
Tom and Peyton are teeing off from the
blue tees which I think will help them
but ultimately the way this first nine
holes are gonna be played is gonna come
down to tiger and Phil carrying their
partners I have them both scoring a four
which is a tie on hole number one all
right on our card we asked will Tom at
the fairway on the hole one that narrow
stretch on your card it's Peyton and
much like us you're going though with
know that he's not going to hit the
fairway how'd you end up on that
decision listen it's the same logic as
the Tom prop both of these guys are good
golfers but they are not great golfers
there's gonna be some nerves here on
this first hole I think neither of them
actually end up in the fairway on this
first hole all right so the front nine
is that best ball format the back nine
is where it's gonna be alternate shot
and you were asked which team leads
after nine holes and you're going with
Tiger and Peyton that presumed favorite
what went into that decision you know
you have to think about here who Adam is
the better golfers on paper tiger and
Peyton are the better golfers and I
think they will prevail in this best
ball format on the front nine Tiger hour
Peyton isn't I think playin a little coy
to how good his game really is as of
late and I think he and Tiger should be
up a stroke or two heading into the back
nine they'll definitely be the more
mentally intense duo and also when the
back tees are known as the tiger tees
and you own the club record that's a
good sign of things to come alright next
one I feel like you've already won the
question was will Tiger Woods wear red
you said yes
and guess what we already have some
footage from out there in the golf
course that shows he's whipped coming
out of that now here's the deal the bet
is will he be wearing red when he tees
off he could absolutely change this is
just what he's wearing in the tunnel
here but you got to be feeling confident
you
feeling confident this is its sun-hee
Tiger wears red on Sunday I thought this
one was way way off in the pricing I
mean I had so many people tell me they
would be absolutely shocked if he did
not wear red today yeah I appreciate
tiger and Phil they know their looks and
they stick with it next one our team the
be our squad had Grunk you have Omaha
well Omaha Spee said by any player a nod
to Peyton Manning pre-snap and you took
know here at minus 180 you don't think
anybody's Yellin Omaha
well Adam a lot of people don't know and
technically I am a Broncos fan and
technically I have you over used the
word Omaha for about the last oh let's
say six or seven years it's played out
at this point I don't think it holds as
much weight unless somehow Tom makes
some ridiculous putt and just slides one
in there I don't think Omaha is gonna be
good I like that a lot
speaking of played out visors the
question was will Phil Mickelson wear a
visor and you have inside information on
this one you said no and the odds have
changed even more in your favor what's
going on there so this one was really
interesting because of course Phil is
gonna wear a visor he's the king of
visors and then I started talking to the
guys that I know that play on the tour
and they said Kelly hello have you not
seen Phil's new hat deal this man is
wearing a ball cap he's not wearing a
visor
it went from plus 110 I saw last night
as high as minus 260 this is absolutely
crazy because Phil Mickelson is no
longer a visor man he wears baseball
caps yeah makes me wonder how the
lettuce is doing in the back anytime you
switch from a visor to a hat maybe you
got something to hide I'll get that
inside information for the course a
little bit later all right your seventh
bet will there be an eagle in the match
you went with no at minus 400 I can't
imagine you've made more bets chalk here
than that this is the Chalky's bet I've
ever made and that's because it is
priced wrong listen we talked about this
prior Adam
these are two professional golfers with
two amateur golfers last weekend we had
four professional golfers and did not
see an eagle while I do think their game
faces are gonna be on going back to this
is a casual type of round and Eagle is a
big ask hey who knows maybe they you
know hold one in and I am eating my
words and crying and my - 400 all hour
parlay ticket I'm hoping that an eagle
is sealed on that fifth hole where
peyton manning uses the butt end of his
6-iron to knock it in that's my dream
and I'm sticking to it
those are seven of Kelly's bets there's
only one bet left just like there's only
one bet left in our card squad who you
got and before we reveal it we talked to
some of the biggest athletes and the
biggest names out there to see where
they weigh in on this epic battle
capital ones the match champions for
charity who you got
I know go I'm not I'm riding with team
Tiger I'm riding with team filled with
Tom Brady I can't I can't go against
Tiger bro she woods this is the battle
this is the one shout-out right there to
the B our graphics team putting all that
together
Shaq my teammate on Tuesdays on NBA on
TNT you didn't have to take that shot on
Chuck he's got to be out there on 18
it's gonna be tough Kelly I'm going
through the app right now we have
hundreds of people weighing in right we
have thousands of people weighing in and
I have to pick one for each side okay
I'm gonna scroll it up here it is and
this guy representing team tiger a
underscore boogie and the boogies got
two zeros for oohs you are representing
team tiger if that's the team that we
end up going with for another one I am
going with cn underscore champ you will
represent team film we are gonna reveal
soon whether or not our squad is going
with team tiger a team fill if it's team
tiger a boogie you win a thousand
dollars of cold hard cash on your couch
if we choose team fill C an underscore
Machamp you are going to win a thousand
dollars of cold hard cash right on your
couch are we ready are we ready we are
ready it is official Kelly our squad is
going with team tiger a boogie
congratulations
you are winning $1,000 and the BR
squad's bet card is officially complete
no yes yes Phil Tom no yes team tiger it
sounds like a t-pain saw but there it is
officially a boogie congratulations you
are gonna be winning $1,000 of Bleacher
Report's money Kelly have you decided
yet who you're going with who you got on
your bad card I have listen Adam you
mentioned earlier that Tiger holds the
course record medalist of a 62 and no
disrespect to Tiger he deserves to be
the favorite at his home course but I
gotta think the value here on the
underdog out of course that rewards his
style of play and that is Phil Mickelson
Mickelson in charge for match play Tiger
again no disrespect
props to your 15 major titles but we
know how you do and made-for-tv events
like this you are just four and five I
had to take that plus 170 I hope that's
still the coeur dog so you guys can jump
on and get the same Adam I'm so excited
I cannot wait to win all these hoodies
alright so again to all my squad members
out there we want to hear Grunk we want
Brady to hit it on the fairway at 1:00
and we are rooting unfortunately against
Chuck on that 18th hole now if you were
to parlay all of our bets you would win
7286 dollars that's on the squad bet if
you were to parlay $100 on all of Ken
Kelley's beds you would win $8,300 and
again this is the squad card we do think
that one of the NFL players Brady R
Manning will hit a ball out of bounds
we're looking for a made drop of Grunk
we need Phil and Tom to get a lead early
here is a recap of some of Kelly's
betting card
she needs a tie on the first hole
Peyton's tee shot she's rooting against
the fairway she don't want an old
she wants Mickelson in the Hat Tiger in
red and against an eagle and again Kelly
is going with team Phil she's
representing Br and we are trying to
beat Br and we are going team tiger I am
going to be on my couch rooting very
hard I'm gonna go put on a red shirt
after this again three o'clock
TNT Capital One's the match champions
for charity all four golfers and Warner
media have already pledged ten million
dollars this is 20 different majors this
is eight Super Bowl champions but
there's only one Kelly Stewart and I'm
curious Kelly do you have any little
nuggets that we can use before we call
our bookie in case we want to beat BR in
the real way Adam you know I love those
big underdog bets and I sifted through
all of them at draftkings and my
favorite one that I call we're gonna
sprinkle a little bit on if you guys
watch the Sunday be our betting show
during the NFL season you know what that
means that means you just take a little
percentage of your bankroll and say you
know what this is worth the flier and
that is Phil Mickelson to birdie hole
number one as he mentioned he hates to
lose I know I said I thought that they
would tie a hole number one but at five
to one this holds tremendous amount of
value if Mickelson gets me a birdie on
hole number one that's it it's done for
me for the rest of the day I'm just
gonna take a break
all right so follow along on the B are
betting channels Kelly you're amazing
except we want to kick your butt
follow along this is going to be the
largest hoodie giveaway that we have
ever done if we do in fact beat Kelly's
card we get more right I have already
gone into the closet I've stolen a ton
to Everett Rachael brill Howard Mitt
mean you can't do anything about it Sam
Tull's I already stole them they're in
my apartment I will personally send it
out to all of you if we beat Kelly
Stewart and I have more good news the
weather gods are smiling upon us the
match champions for charity will will
tee off at 3:30 right there on TNT thank
you guys so much for joining us here on
the BR app we hope you've enjoyed the
experience this will not be the last
time that we try to beat bee
are when there's major sports this is
where you need to bet guys enjoy
yourself enjoy your capital ones that
match champions for charity for Kelly
Stewart for everybody here at bleacher
report that made this possible from
production to social to programming to
marketing we appreciate you guys it is
live sports time get on TV follow along
on social it's been a pleasure now get
to that sign it's golfin time
[Music]
[Music]